he followed me closely staring at a
chilled and laid-back frog became a hate
symbol
hacked online by far right groups the
internet is
a place where people believe in
expansive freedom of expression
this is not a fight over a cartoon frog
this is a fight about political speech
is this cartoon frog a symbol of free
speech
or artwork hijacked by racist hate
groups
pepe as he's known has been labeled a
nazi
condemned by a presidential candidate
and now is at the center of an important
legal battle over the first amendment
in this era of unlimited replication
imitation and mutation
it's a fight that involves the alt-right
trump voters
one of washington dc's most powerful law
firms and the website 4chan
aka the [ __ ] of the internet
pepe the frog is the creation of a
38-year-old cartoonist from ohio named
matt fury who declined to be interviewed
for this story
the anthropomorphic frog first appeared
12 years ago in fury's web comic
boys club in the series most famous
sequence pepe
is caught standing at a toilet with his
pants around his ankles
as he later explains feels good man
it wasn't until a few years later when
someone posted his image to the
anonymous online image board 4chan that
pepe became a global phenomenon the
feels bad man pepe emerged followed by
sad frog and so on pepe was tweeted out
by
katy perry and instagrammed by nicki
minaj
and matt fury defended the anonymous
people on the internet who had turned
his creation
into an unstoppable meme but then pepe
became something else
entirely pepe is a white nationalist
symbol one of the david's
racist rights has been added to the
anti-defamation league's database of
hate symbols
it's been a nightmare for matt
fury intellectual property attorney
louis tompro says matt fury contacted
his firm wilmer hale after pepe appeared
in what he describes as an islamophobic
children's book in which pepe does
battle with a bearded alligator and what
appear to be his burka-clad minions
but that was just the beginning pepe's
recent evolution into a right-wing
symbol
most likely started on 4chan's poll page
a board devoted to facilitating
politically incorrect conversation that
became a haven for donald trump
supporters in 2016.
images of pepe wearing red mega hats
proliferated and donald trump jr even
posted an
image that included a trumpified version
of pepe to social media
the clinton campaign responded by
branding pepe a
symbol associated with white supremacy
the emerging racist
ideology known as the alt right
enter mike cernovich whether it's
exposing congressman john conyers sexual
harassment scandal or publicly
threatening to publish the shitty men in
media list
cernovich has a knack for leveraging his
large social media presence to catapult
himself into the news cycle
most people in the fake news media who
get to that high level
are pedophiles we're not alt-right and
we're not
old school national review take the high
road boring right
we're very aggressive we've taken over
for example
the microphones at left wing rallies
bill clinton the rapist he raped juanita
broderick the media covered it up
bill clinton is a rapist i want
everybody to know bill we're in a meme
world
we're in a world where you have to be
catchy punchy that's how you're actually
influencing voters that's how you
actually are persuading people
to accept your ideas as true so we're a
bunch of
kind of merry meme makers cernovich
posted a fan made video on his youtube
channel that incorporates hillary
clinton's audiobook description of what
it felt like
sharing the debate stage with trump
there's an excerpt where she goes and he
was stalking me
breathing down my neck i felt so creeped
out referring to trump
and then you have pepe kind of stalking
hillary clinton no matter where i walked
he followed me closely staring at me
making faces it was incredibly
uncomfortable
and i thought this is art fury's
attorney sent cernovich a takedown
notice
he complied but also hired free speech
lawyer mark randazza to draft a response
the way i try to explain fair use to
people is that you can take a whole
bunch of
already created works and when you take
them all together and then you blow new
life into that
a new thought is expressed through that
you probably have engaged in what's
called fair use
you can't copy other people's ideas
and claim free speech that's not how the
first amendment works it's not how
copyright law works
they're absolutely free to just to spout
hate in some other form
we just don't want them using pepe the
frog to do it on a human level
i have tremendous empathy for fury
i think he made a tremendous mistake by
not
getting ahead of the pepe usage i think
he matt fury could be a
a worldwide name worldwide brand and
that he could have actually
beat the people who are using pepe in
ways he didn't like by
spreading more pepe images fury's
attorneys have gone a step further in
the case of a kansas city-based artist
named jessica logsdon
who refused to take down the pepe themed
paintings she sells on ebay for 99 cents
plus
37 shipping they filed a lawsuit against
logsdon who declined to appear in this
video
but responded via email that while she
may appear confident
she's rational enough to be scared
because wilmer hale
is a titan of law she also attached a
picture of a new painting she calls
wilbur fail we're not trying to do this
because she's some kind of a small fish
had she simply complied with the dmca
notice and our request
there's no question we would not have
brought a lawsuit
i had a brief conversation with her and
she
sent me as a gift i think
if you can see it over my shoulder what
is now one of my favorite works of art
if i were
still teaching copyright law classes i
would bring this in
as an example of classic fair use i
believe that things can be memed into
the public domain
you know the picture of the little kid
with his fists like that you know i
don't know who originally took that
picture
whoever did if they were to try to lasso
control of that picture at this point
i think they would fail miserably but i
think the result would be a
thousand times more people reusing it
because
the internet is a place where people
believe
in expansive freedom of expression and
sometimes the greatest way
to set a fire on the internet is to try
to blow out one candle
fury is demanding logsden seize her
display and sale of any pepe imagery and
that the court award damages and
unlawful profits 4channers have
responded by projecting images of pepe
on the wilmer hale office building
the case has yet to go to trial but it
could set a legal precedent
better defining the blurry line between
the free speech rights of internet meme
makers
and the copyright claims of artists this
is a fight about a big
multinational multi-billion dollar
corporation
going after not me because i'm a big
name but going after very small people
who don't have the resources it takes
this is law fair this is not
a david versus goliath case this is a
situation where
if anything the little guy here is matt
fury
who's an artist trying to to make sure
that his
his work is protected copyright is not
just there to incentivize you to create
but it's also there to create
a larger marketplace of ideas it is not
there
so that you can say i'm upset about how
my work is being portrayed about how my
work's being talked about
how about how my work is now being used
in a transformative manner
and i'm gonna put a lockdown on that you
don't get to do that matt fury
the frog is on the loose